damit ist luca meine lieben freunde ich
darf euch heute recht herzlich
willkommen also endlich mal wieder einer
neuen episode tik tok tuesday ich habe
schon länger keine tik tok megson
hochgeladen deswegen bin ich richtig
heiß auf den ersten clip heute
[Musik]
ich weiß wie solange nicht hochgeladen
haben
irgendwie
haben wir hier immer nur so verstörende
clips
was
[Musik]
was kommt als nächstes eine frau die
sich nur salami als ohrring ans ohr
[Musik]
ich dachte wirklich ich
mache scheiß content auf tik tok
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber diese videos auf die ich reagieren
sind wirklich eine andere liga
[Musik]
entspannt
es ist auch ein bisschen mich selbst
weil ich diesen schwachsinn auf meiner
homepage angezeigt bekommen
das traurige ist halt der vogel hat
immer noch einen besseren haircut als
ich habe da haben dort gar keine zeit
wird
[Musik]
sich
beck
[Musik]
das erste video war dass die klage muss
ist ein golden retriever der auf demente
dritte
[Musik]
runde und gerne rast die einfach sandra
im gym gefilmt haben
[Musik]
ich hab mal geguckt ob du mir genauso
aussieht
tut es nicht er fängt an zu regnen
[Musik]
ich habe da schon
sagen fleck den muss ich kurz ein
bisschen genauer wegwischen er leitet
ist aber dass niemand gebaut wie finde
es heißt das es ist sehr hübsch ist
[Musik]
das sehr schön er leite ist aber eines
nie baby gemma wie viel das weiß dass es
ist sehr so
auch den schnee baby
ist sehr schön
etwas anderes man als stimmen bauen
[Musik]
ja
es gibt manchmal leckerei
[Musik]
was
moin ich will's laser lag
ja
wenn ihr noch mehr dummheit hören wollt
ist patrick ebert und lästig und du
alter dachte die zu beginn auch er ist
dass das unfassbar hoch sei 30 meter
lang aber damals jedoch nur drei oder so
hat trotzdem zum alter der wand runter
trieb was sich der sich zu beginn
es gibt so krasse werbungen und
meine werbung ist seit jahren einfach
[Musik]
geht auch nicht weg dieser fleck
wahrheit
[Musik]
wenn das auch immer mehr
kurzem hintergrundstory dazu es war
einmal witzig war im wald in der nähe
von frankfurt irgendwo schnee lag und
ich war spazieren
da gab es ein pärchen an und die meinten
sie habe tochter guckt immer deine
videos und kann nicht mal ein foto für
die zusammen machen und ich sagte 'komm
das video machen viel geiler viel
persönlicher sollte die frau sowie ihrem
mann einkommen immer das handy filme und
er dachte halt gegen wie er dreht dann
seinen hollywood streifen wenn du fängst
du oben an
es gibt jetzt habe ich wieder kurz groß
wie die
automatische update 1
ja
ich will vielleicht aus einem
kieferorthopäden
da machen wir ganz schnell weiter alle
reden zwar von 2 g aber du bist für mich
eins a
wie können solche videos von sony und
mir immer viral gehen auf tik tok das
ding hat auch schon fast zwei millionen
aufrufe
jetzt nicht was daran falsch schützen
was das auch immer so
ich habe ganz viele fragen das leben ist
wie schach weiß das leben schwarzer tod
weiß beginnt schwarz gewinnt
als x
[Musik]
2 tickets die lachen müssen im ersten
hat ein hund fast getötet und beim
zweiten wird irgendein für die möglichen
gerne emotionaler spruch mit haltbar
auseinandergenommen
an der stelle würde ich euch allerdings
das heutige wir jetzt auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat
das geld einen daumen hoch oder dem
wieder abonniert main kanal und klickt
auf die glocke wenn die weitere videos
nicht verpassen wollt folgt die mission
aufstieg doch wenn nicht warum
ich heiser laser luca und wenn ihr nicht
folgen wollt dann kann ich euch sanders
konnten empfehlen der es nämlich super
dass ich schon letzte woche